hey guys we've got another interview for
you right now with two of the stars from
the great Elle Fanning and Nicholas
Hoult hello hello how are you guys doing
good how are you well first off the show
is something else and you are both
phenomenal in it but we're gonna talk
about a little bit of everything right
now and I wanted to go back to the very
beginning because you are two people who
have had great experience in the
industry at a very young age so would
you say that there was a first
collaborator that made the biggest
impression on you that you find yourself
still thinking about that collaboration
today I mean I don't know if it's
something that one of my first
experiences making a film was with you
gone on on about a boy and that's
certainly something that I don't I don't
think I purposefully do but occasionally
people will say that there's things I do
particularly with in Tony's writing Tony
McNamara who wrote the favorite and the
great there's occasionally moments that
people think that I've kind of taken
things that Hugh does and stolen them
and run with them maybe a little bit and
I don't purposely do that but I take it
as a compliment when people do say that
I have taken some of his we all we kind
of all grown evolved from our
experiences so you're supposed to do
that yeah have at you oh yeah um for me
what sticks out I did a movie with Sally
Potter called ginger and Rosa she
directed me in it and just that whole
experience I was I just turned 13 like
the teenage you know nearly a teenager
and something about that character
I felt so unlike myself and I learned so
much from Sally on that and just has a
on a personal level and I had my first
kiss ever in that movie and she used and
I tried that cool and say like yeah like
I like kissed a lot of people before um
but she used like the first kiss that
take in like years later she's like I
used the
No and when I knew that you never had
and that's on camera for everyone to see
forever but I think yeah you were 13 and
you were like oh I've kissed a lot of
people yeah I was trying I was trying to
be like no big deal actually kind of
speaking of that because I've asked this
question to a bunch of people and and
some have said the first kiss type thing
but what's what's the question that you
wished you had had the nerve to ask
earlier on that you felt silly asking as
far as you know how things work on a
film set go I think I'm still asking
silly questions most days on how things
work or like I know it takes a long time
to understand a film set and that's
something that I'm starting to get a
better grip of like understanding all
the things that play that end up then on
screen at the end and and how that
process comes about I think that the
editing process is something that
obviously normally as an actor you kind
of finish your part of the job and then
and then you kind of see a version of
what you shot six months a year later
and you can like oh well okay that's
interesting so that's that's part of the
process I'm getting more interested in
trying to understand better now so I can
kind of grasp what goes on in that in
that arena and then how that affects why
I'm doing on set yeah I was gonna say
that getting behind the lens you're
yourself and giving that ago um yeah I
mean I would love to I got to be a
producer on this which was very new
territory but something I've always I'm
so interested in everyone's part on a
film set and how it all comes to be and
so getting to be like kind of a part of
the process of the beginning stages of
it I've liked going to pitches and like
go you know to streamys are like being
in those rooms and hearing how people
speak about projects when I'm normally
always just on the creative side but to
get a little bit more on the business
side it's it goes at the same time and
you know it is a business too so it's
like
it is art but there's another side to it
as well which in those rooms I got to
see a bit more of which I am kind of I
am fascinated by it's exciting to hear
that you're getting into producing
because I feel like that's that's such a
big deal when you have a voice and you
want to tell particular types of stories
that might not get made unless you know
you put your weight behind it so if we
get more things like the great because
of that work that you're getting into
are there are there any particular goals
you have as a producer like a certain
type of film a certain type of voice
that you want to help get out there more
than what we have now yeah I think I
think for me I just kind of growing up
from a young age in the business I I've
started to learn I think there's a lot
of great examples before me that I do
have of like you know Reese Witherspoon
for example it's like she you know it's
wild right like that was something that
she kind of made herself it was like she
wanted to play a certain type of
character that she didn't see out there
and she's like you know what I'm gonna
try to make this happen and so I'm
always and and ears a little bit more
open of when I read books or just like
an article that I love or find
fascinating I think for me just and it
doesn't necessarily you know of course
you I female driven stories always
interest me because I'm a female but but
then at the same time I just love good
stories too so I'm not trying to put
myself in a box in that way really for
sure I feel like yeah neither of you
have put yourself in the in a box with a
great range of work you've delivered so
it does make me wonder back in the day
when you guys were first starting out
did you ever kind of label yourselves or
your goals in a way like I want to be an
action star I want to be a superhero
anything like that and then find
yourself in a place where you're saying
I can't believe I'm here doing this kind
of role right now there was never an aim
like oh I wanted to be an action star
clearly or any of those sorts of things
because I don't know it's quite
unpredictable this this line of
work anywhere you never sure what script
might end up in your pile to read next
so it's kind of has always been a
conscious effort on my part to not try
and take the easy route and to try and
play varied characters and different
styles of genres I guess in movies and
shows and and characters but there's
never yeah there's never been like oh
this is what I want to do I want to put
myself in that Lane because and in the
fun of acting is being able to kind of
keep a variety of it and I think I'd get
bored if I was doing the same kind of
thing over and over again so that's what
I love and that's why this was such a
fun thing to take on because I haven't
done TV for a while Tony's writing such
a singular voice this character is
something that I don't feel like I've
played but it's like a lot of fun
because there's not a lot of barriers
within playing him so it's just kind of
those those options I guess of keeping
things fresh and and new and and that
stops me from getting bored and
hopefully stops people from getting
bored of watching me last time we spoke
I think it was for for killing your
friends you do have a knack for playing
a jerk I find it so endlessly
entertaining they are very entertaining
characters to play and particularly a
particular because he's so funny he's
just odd he has no sense or
understanding of other people's feelings
or emotions really and what he says and
how it affects them so he comes out with
bizarre things that are outrageous and
horrible and hurtful but also at times
kind of honest and funny from his
perspective I mean they're kind of funny
from the viewer perspective too even
though I know he's terrible to everybody
around him know what about for you did
you did you set any personal goals for
yourself early on that you you exceeded
in a way you didn't expect oh god no no
no I have it like that's what's funny
like I feel like I have not done
everything I want to or want to try I
think like I very similarly he's like
again stealing all mix answers but I
just like I love a challenge and love to
be able to morph myself into someone
that I feel like
I'm I'm completely not like front
forever for me like acting course is fun
and is a job and but you know starting
young it was like dress up in this form
of make-believe and keeping that kind of
childlike imagination alive and like
that's truly what it still is for me and
I feel like I really thrive in
situations when I'm terrified or like
under pressure and I'm like up against
myself that I have to it's like it's
like I make it a do-or-die situation
like and I love that feeling I feel like
I love teetering on the tightrope and I
definitely felt like many days like that
and when I was playing Katherine in the
great I don't know if it was just I felt
like I was very much out of my comfort
zone but then that's a comfortable place
for me to be and I got to explore more
sides to myself and got to know knocks
and walls down that I've probably had up
maybe that's just the comedy of it all
to that to explore that a bit more
because I haven't truly done comedy
maybe on this on this level of when
you're like have to deliver a joke and
you want you actually want the audience
to laugh you know like I haven't really
had so yeah it was um yeah it was a
different I always try to just dude very
different roles try to as far as getting
people to laugh great success with with
this one I'm only halfway through I was
too afraid to binge them all and then
run the risk of spoiling the show for
everybody but I mean like to be
completely honest I sometimes judge a
period piece by its poster or whatever
you want to say and I just assume I'm
not gonna like it and this this proved
me wrong big time yeah it's in a
different category of period piece one
one weird thing that gets in my head so
Nick am I crazy that I think every
single Palace setting is the same place
as the favorite
not no you're not insane you can when we
were when we were shooting the pilot for
this we shot a Hatfield house which is
one of the places to be shot a fair
amount of the flavor as well so so
you're actually very perceptive okay I
feel like now I'm saying there's another
relief apparently now I can always spot
that location the house from the movie
insidious or the house from Billy
Madison if I lose everything else at
least I have that skill set before we
get into the great here I also wanted to
ask you both about jumping into major
film franchises because I really can't
even imagine the pressure of jumping
into something like x-men or like
Maleficent so when you're going into
something that big especially for the
very first time is it a no-brainer to
want to take this potentially
game-changing opportunity or are you
sitting there and kind of weighing the
value of the pressure of being
associated with a really popular brand
you I think try and always weigh up each
each job in character and what you're
going into with the same kind of
assessment I suppose going in and what
the character is who's directing or
who's producing who's making the film
and what the story is and what the
character is if it's something that you
can feel you can bring something to and
have a have an angle on but there nor so
yeah there's definitely I suppose from
my standpoint if there's if it is a big
franchise like that I mean it's
different because I you know with x-men
I'm playing a supporting role and then
that's actually a lot of weight lifted
from you going into those things because
it's not riding on your back you're
getting to be a part of something that's
a lot bigger than you and that's where
it's actually very freeing so I really
thrive and enjoy that that idea but yeah
definitely in in the past and when you
get offered kind of those bigger
tentpole movies that maybe is relying
more on you as a lead character that is
something that you have to kind of look
at in a different way because like I was
saying earlier it is a business so
people kind of do
judge you on how those films perform
more so than if you go and do an indie
film that doesn't work out and people
don't particularly see so it is it is a
different assessment I suppose from from
your angle always got to look at it from
a creative standpoint first but there
are different kind of things that play I
suppose with that has the x-men
experience kind of changed your opinion
on signing on for future franchises
because I know this was completely out
of your control but you and you made
such a big him even though it is an
ensemble series you made such a [ __ ]
impression on that franchise and what
happened to it was entirely out of your
control so does that kind of put a bug
in your head when the next thing comes
knocking on your door for like a multi
film deal where you know you got to
commit no matter what the industry and
the future for the industry holds
it's tricky those are the any multi
length sort of deal is interesting to
sign onto it because it can shape your
future quite a lot and also it's an odd
thing because yeah as you say you don't
always have complete control over it the
only thing that you can rely on is there
hopefully if something's good and people
like it then it keeps going and that
means that you'll obviously want to keep
being involved with it and it would the
x-men experience I had like I've made so
many brilliant friends and had such a
great time making them and and love all
the people involved so so it certainly
is not some oh yeah if those sorts of
things came about again where it's a
multi deal whatever it's not something
that I'd be intimidated by under the
right circumstances
so pivoting to the type of commitment
that a series requires I mean what is it
like committing to a show like the great
versus a feature film it's especially
with the the variation in the shooting
schedule do you have to give a series
any more thought to actually you know
have that chunk of your schedule taken
up by that yes I mean the I think that
it just means that like I would like the
series has to be something that I truly
believe in and that I fully want to give
all of my time to because it does take I
mean it took six months for us but then
again I mean some of the really big big
movies do take that long I mean I
Maleficent kind of it did take six
months but that's kind of the only film
that I've done that was of that scale so
I'm six months for me in a film like in
a film world is really really a lot like
we did the beguiled in like 20 days like
I'm used to like 20 days shoots so it's
not like so like whoa sick so it's my
life half my year and what you know also
you do think well what other
opportunities am I gonna miss out on
like it has to all be it has to be worth
it you know you have to believe in it
and with this show it was really not
there was no debate like for me it was
the firt when I read the script and was
included it was there was no thought I
didn't I didn't think it was a gut
reaction and like I had to do it like I
had to so I think that that's that's a
gift like when you have that feeling you
know in it and it's all worth it you at
that between between the two of you who
signed on to this first else and you put
it together yeah but yeah but I also
guess I mean I mean but I feel like when
I first heard about it to like Toni was
working with you or the face like Toni
knew you from the favorite and we've
done that and yeah and like he's Peter
like that was it so I always knew that
that was that you were gonna be him Toni
always said that so you guys finally
come together on this and I know with a
lot of indie films especially you don't
really have all that much rehearsal time
but it almost feels like like the
beating heart of this show is your
cadence together and the tone
established so do you guys get the
appropriate amount of time to you know
play around and kind of find that
together before you jump on set I think
we both we both work in a very similar
manner and both kind of come with the
same level of preparedness to each day
to filming and kind of sometimes not so
prepared because you have a lot of
dialogue to learn and a lot of time to
learn and
that you move out is very fast on TV but
also we else you said this before where
we kind of enjoy kind of the tit-for-tat
and battling each other within a scene
and that's why I characters do a lot
within this and Tony writes such fun
scenes for that to happen with him but
it's it's just enjoyable and then we get
to play around and have fun so there's
always enough time on set to get what we
need but there's not always as much
rehearsal but then also when you've been
playing with these characters for a long
time like like we do by the end of this
you kind of have an understanding of
what what the scene is or what the what
you're going to be bringing to it and
then it's just about finding that
balance and and what what the story is
I'm just curious because you guys seem
to be so in sync what what happens when
you have a co-star where maybe you're
not as in sync or your process is
extremely different do you guys kind of
have you know tools in the toolbox in
order to adjust to that I mean something
you're gonna like Mickey is like like
the best sparring partner like yours
like there's just like there's something
like that with us we completely click
you know and we I think it's also
because we work the same way and then
inevitably you are and I've experienced
this where you sometimes work with
people that oh like they do things very
differently not that it's wrong you know
that's there everyone has their own
thing that they do and I respect all
that but I don't know some time and but
it is it is harder like with Nick it's
like I don't know it makes it much
easier you know and more fun it makes it
also just like enjoyable on that way
which you know matters in life also
working with someone who operates
differently than you maybe you pick some
of their techniques oh I don't know over
the course of course you learn from you
learn from from everyone on set of how
you know what their what they do and I
can't think it like something oh so
specific or like how you deal with it I
mean I don't know I've always been I
didn't go to acting school you know
anything I grew up on said and so I feel
like my lessons and everything I learned
was from other people who were very
different for me and and directors that
work a different way and I don't I also
feel like I'm not necessarily someone
that has this method or that I need
rehearsal or that I need this it's like
I kind of like to experiment and like
alright this director wants us to all
dance like crazy together alright not
necessarily I would do but I'll try it
out and it's all part of that one
experience you know that movie that
experience it makes that character
unique in a different way because it was
a totally different process so I try to
embrace like each process each person's
process if that makes sense I try to
embrace it fully and just go for that
and then my own homework and like what I
do at home is my own separate thing that
I probably can't really explain but
that's my grounding and then I'm
prepared enough to be spontaneous and
try the weird idea you know that that
you would never think of and it kind of
that collaboration makes for something
very different you know and that was you
know interesting on this is that in TV
you have different directors and that
was like whoa like that was new for me
I've never done TV and so getting used
to how each director works but then
they're also fitting into a list of
rules that we have for our show and
trying to follow our rules and then we
feel like we know our characters the
best you know so they're coming in and
and you're wanting to get their ideas
and they're adding a new flavor so it
was I was though that was something that
took adjusting for me I think - I would
get used to a director bit oh you know
we're we're getting on and then boom oh
they're gone like someone's coming in
tomorrow so and just the pace of that
but I think it added something it adds
for something very refreshing because
each episode also has a different you
know point of view and and stuff
absolutely your ensemble is Finn
and also of everybody I want to name
drop them all right now but if you had
to pick one member of the ensemble who
when you read their role on the page
what they wound up doing with it was
something completely different that you
didn't even expect who would you pick
and why I know who you're gonna say Nick
Who am I gonna say they're gonna say
Doug yeah I loved I loved watching Doug
Douglas hard you played elemental I
thought he did yeah he took a character
that on the page was it was a great and
well-written and but then he brought so
much to it and just made me giggle in
every single say in his physicality all
the mannerisms of the character and then
also watching that character evolve
through the series as well and I think
he's brilliant and each time I was on
the same with him it would make it would
make me laugh and I'd look forward to it
so yeah I really love Sasha how he plays
or low or low is just like I feel like
he's the heart of the show like I just
love him I love him again but he really
is something else yes just like his
neuroses and all the little details that
Sasha brings to it's really incredible
all right to dip into a little future
stuff before I let you guys go el one of
your things that I am so so excited for
is the nightingale
because I'd correct me if I'm wrong I
think this is the first time you're
leading a movie with your sister and I
love Mel or Melanie Laurent too
so what was it about that particular
script that made you to say now is the
time we you're gonna lead a movie
together yeah I think there you know
there have been scripts in the past even
when we were much younger which I'm glad
we didn't do I think now that were we've
grown even you know in our relationship
and where we where we are now this is
just the perfect timing to finally work
together and kind of bring each other
into that artistic world like because
we're not we don't talk about work with
each other so and we've actually heard
from the people that we work very
differently on sets so like be curious
to find out how it is but it's just it's
such a special um
a special project and story and it's
truly also about sisters and that's
something that I think you know we
deliberated about you or like should we
want to play sisters maybe we could just
like you know be something else entirely
but like we are sisters and that dynamic
I think we can really bring that to the
screen you know we we know that dynamic
have you seen any of the fan casting for
you as Batgirl because I also know
nikrif and has spoken about directing a
Batgirl movie or at least what is so
funny about this because well Nick and I
Nick from the very start like I don't
know why I don't know why he does this
but from the moment like I met him I was
16 he my nick name is Batgirl to him so
he'll always and he's uh
Robin Robin Wonder Boy so he'll say like
hey bad girl like it's Robin ones like
always so like we we were like just
joking like oh my god like are they
making minutes like Bert because he's
always called me that I feel like that's
a sign it's meant to be
yeah it's meant to be yeah I think Nick
I don't know if they would he'll do an
out-there version okay for commercial it
would most certainly be unique whatever
you guys do sign on for next after this
I mean I'm just rooting for you all day
long the more stuff you guys make the
better but in the meantime we've got the
great Lulu may 15th all 10 episodes will
be available I cannot recommend them
enough go watch them again guys thank
you so much for your time today thank
you so much thanks so much